hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bob and Wade and this
is drunk minecraft with Bob and Wade say
hi Bob hi guys hi Bob say hi Wayde Wayde
as your Dajjal wait is a doggy fade up
Caddyshack well okay anyway so Wade has
been turned into a donkey we hired a
witch and took the pile of sand and
turned it into the donkey on the
downside steam yeah on the downside that
that pile of sound turned into a giant
desert and trapped us here so we are
gonna set out on the Minecraft trail
mm-hmm okay anyway so we need to collect
our supplies what are we gonna bring for
this trip I hopefully some food uh no
food I've got iron horse what cures
dysentery
nothing nothing cures disappear crap I
just had armored my horse where did you
get oh my god I want a horse arm no
deserve horse armor you suck I don't
know how it must have magically fell out
of the sky
scooch away from you so I might actually
catch magical sky fairies hey
something's pushing me some magical
invisible thing is pushing me I want oh
I want all great sky demon but Scott
needs supplies for my trip across the
desert is this how we're gonna talk you
think it is oh my god it's back oh no is
it is it really his mask you sure miss
back your bub Bob what mask you shim man
mask myself say that phrase in the way
that Wade would say it now that he's a
donkey oh yeah
ah that's good that was good okay how's
that so we got our twenty grandfather
clocks we're ready to go we're ready to
go I need horse armor no deserve horse
armor oh we're gonna go there's this all
you see that mysterious horse that's
just standing over there weirdly kind of
jumping around worse I don't I don't
think that horse is natural but anyway
we're gonna continue this way so follow
me into the desert yeah
Oh Clementine wait what what's weakly
Cletus Cletus I'm old Cletus
we're gonna go right into the freaking
ocean apparently what okay it wasn't
loaded yet I thought it was the ocean
either allows the ocean never free
notion before you keel cuke okay so
anyway I guess this would be what you
call a beach yeah except tank my god oh
my god what I'm killing wait I keep
dragging him into gases don't kill Wade
we love Wade questions are gonna keep up
man
Wade uh yeah Wade's it's a bit too shot
dad's I know
Wade just a bit too stupid to be able to
make decisions for himself ergo we the
intelligent ones will continue onward oh
we forgot to mention we're playing
what you call Minecraft 1.6 yeah yeah
it's a improvement on 1.5 cuz there's
horsies now yeah obviously the addition
of horses was exactly the only thing in
the ha ha ha ha oh my god it's nighttime
already oh no we lost my ID why the lead
just like falls off for no reason so
there's a lot of lag there's like I got
a huge amounts of latency but that's ok
ok hey this is one Paul oh my god the
zombies are gonna eat way oh we don't
know oh wait water found water Cletus
fan water we have like bottles to her
i'm i'm fording the river hope I don't
get dysentery yeah oh my supplies don't
get swept away ah oh my gosh Oh No
okay all right oh that one dysentery
feels like what happened why did the
world end Wow there is no organ I don't
think I don't think that's a thing how
do we get to organ if we already found
the engineer that's there some magical
sky demon has some explaining to do what
the hell I don't know I think the
sources are raping each other I think
those villages are having sex in there
ah only I could operate boxes and gates
and stuff yeah Abby's apples would be so
awesome to be able to do these things
but alas we must rely on the gift of the
gods well why don't we fall off the edge
of the year why does that have to happen
to us we're good people right right oh
crap now I'm trapped inside trapped in
the hall where I went inside this house
but I can't open or close the door by
myself so I don't know how I got in
there Oh are they having sex in here Oh
what do they have these are eyes who
were just trapped in here behind this
fancy this Joe Jose Manuel and the other
guy doesn't have a name and his clone he
doesn't have a name oh oh I can't get
out here ha ha ha ah ha ha now the
children are coming know about you we'll
never get to Oregon if you don't help me
wait a minute that's not a child I think
mark is dying of dysentery Oh
oh my god ha no one's dying of dysentery
yet so anyway we need new horses
hey those horses out here Hey look right
ok Oh oh my god they don't like you
it bucked me oh my god how do you
domesticate horses keep mounting them
apparently that's important uh hang on
this one it's gonna it's gonna accept me
whether it likes it or not I'm gonna I'm
gonna stay on you all right okay all
right fine all right okay I ran okay
zombie help us don't I why aren't you
helping huh huh how keep it oh hey
thanks for the inker okay I finally got
this thing domesticated maybe almost how
do you do it just stay on it for a long
time it's trying to bite my face now
that I've got a lien on it
ah okay now I'm getting on the horse I'm
ready to go you ready to go no I know we
need to get the shipment of the
moonshine to the moonshiner Knights you
know in moonshine village cuz they would
need moonshine domesticated horses
domesticated cool I got a saddle on mine
they is wild creatures they need the
heart love oh I'll give them the hard
love huh huh huh you think my joke was
funny Bob no that's all oh you're shy
all right which way did we go before uh
a waif this we went this way then I'm
going so we should go the other way huh
wait no did we go that way I don't think
we went that way I think we went that
way I'm pretty sure we went that way Bob
Bob why there why are there rails over
here what's good is that a mine oh let's
go this way then I guess wait would that
way okay all right hard I'm trusting you
on this one Bob wait we don't have wait
does waiting so wait is dead forever oh
yeah we threw weight off the edge of the
earth and he's got and I put a lead on
these villagers ha ha ha
ah last zoo up some villages anyway we
need to make you to Oregon so we get the
shipments of moonshine to the moon China
nights oh oh
let's go gotta go he's gotta go you
behind me Bob right here I've got
another horse in case yours dies why
would why would mine die
I don't know why would a dial it's my
faster than yours am i kicking your ass
lagging like a lot so excuse me
well maybe mine is slow it's a bit it's
got more hearts but it might be bigger
and bulkier I bet that two thing I bet
they all have different like store to
stats and whatnot
right I pray that sounds like the kind
of thing guys who play Minecraft yeah ha
ha ha what else did they add at one
point sake just horses is that the only
reason for this okay yeah just it's
called the horse update really is that
what it's called I don't know I'm sure
there's some other stuff I I I don't
know hmm yeah I see something in the
distance
what is it Oregon no it's more desert oh
okay
is that what organ is no I don't think
so
okay why why would you be traveling
across treacherous desert to get to more
treads desk
I don't know why are you so far ahead of
me why are you waiting you're slow I'm
trying to go faster but this oh this is
why we were before is not you're a liar
I am currently standing in the dysentery
pond it is where we were before not
standing in the dysentery pond you're
standing right in front of me you're not
in the dysentery pond I on my screen I
mean it isn't anywhere near a dysentery
what are you doing what are you doing
there Bob Bob or is this just a mirage
are there mirages in this is that new -
don't know oh they're okay I see it wait
you you you were over there I see you
now but you were there I saw you I saw
you with my own eyes magic Oh dad I got
dysentery yeah uh why why
Wow two hours later and we still haven't
found Oregon I bet if we took two hours
we would still not find Oregon okay I'm
gonna come back to the town and go the
correct way which way is the correct way
I don't know one that I said to go
okay I'm gonna domesticate me another
horsie
I could bring yours back but I'm not
gonna know cuz you're a lazy Oh Oh how's
that dysentery taste ha huh whoa like
pus or whatever it tastes like I don't
know what it's dysentery tastes like I
don't know I've never had dysentery or
drank it for that matter all right I'm
gonna get ready to go I'm all water my
horse up oh the one of myself up by the
way everybody this is the world's
biggest amaretto sour it's good I don't
think spamming your spacebar helps are
you ready to go yes love me love me just
keep right-clicking on it just spam
right click on it that's what works for
me mine loved me in record time
whoa what was that something fell from
the sky Bob well something fell from the
sky I swear something fell from the sky
oh I believe you
or am I seeing things again are you
ready to go yeah yeah oh this is the
right way right yes yeah yeah yeah you
got a fast horse and I got a shitty wah
ha ha what now you making fun of me
Laurie Americans Oh whew
ow hope you remember kind you go gloomy
okay anyway so we need to get the
shipments of grandfather clocks Wade is
dead who gives a [ __ ] about him but
what were you why were you an organ we
didn't plan this out wait what is this
there's some stoneware this this looks
like a thing it's just wait there's gold
oh ah gonna need part thousand oh wow oh
sorry Horace how are you holding these
birds yeah we need our pickaxes now
can't you do gold with your hands oh no
you'll break it
you'll destroy it Oh horsies leaving
horses how that I guess we can't all my
god I'm killing my horse on characters
ah I guess we can't get this gold know
oh you don't get gold Oh was that bye
wait that was my Hershel voice I totally
forgot about it
Oh Marshall no oh it's not the same
without Wade Hey look horses Oh what is
that is that Marauders oh no there's no
one on horses okay
wild horses can't kill horses yeah keep
me away whatever is that a song that's a
song your singing is keeping me alive
Bob keep doing it I will never stop uh
yeah about that
now I keep going I kill my horse he's
not doing very well I don't know whoa
stop for some chopped-up I jumped him
onto the top of the cabbage on top yeah
I think well how do we get to work I
don't know ha ha ha I don't know what
the hell
there is no organ I'm poisoned
laughs dysentery ha ha
Bob Turner good healthy hello I'm dying
of dysentery I'm [ __ ] so much it
hurts you ha ha ha ha I know I'm down to
one health please help me Bob I'm gonna
die I'm gonna die
ah why Bob like crap your horse is
sinking into the earth what you did you
killed me why did you kill me I didn't
you kill me look at the console I don't
recall who you kill Bay how dare you you
know what I'm screwed or again it's a
TNT war I've been fighting Oregon on my
own declare TNT war
we're gonna have an Old West shoot-out
hang on is there muskets how we don't
help ghosts are there oh no we're not in
second yeah but we have bows and arrows
we're gonna do an Old West duel here ha
ha you come out of that building I'll
come out of this building then we'll
come shooting I'm so not even where you
are right no you I sure hope you get
dysentery like right ok so I've been
changing my socks
I'm probably not gonna get dysentery
maybe like there's absolutely no reason
that I should get dysentery right you
got really thirsty drank some bad water
and you really were not careful about
who you were with and oh god no ha ha ha
ha ha oh I was with dysentery is not an
S shut up you don't know that they don't
know what dysentery is oh no oh I'm not
dying yeah see I apparently go down to
one bar until someone punches you in the
back
oh that's bad huh I shouldn't have done
that mmm so magical sky God we're gonna
do some bows and arrows for this oh my
god I found a mountain I wish I could
see the mountain if only a head and died
like a morrow that mountain organ
problems got why they exist organ so I
think YouTube
what does organ look like ah whoo holy
crap my horse can climb the mountain
like a pro oh oh well fantastic for you
isn't that wonderful for you please tell
me that was dysentery kicking in I'm
still almost dead huh well I want that
one last ah ha ha ha ha oh no ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha got ya where'd you go
respawn please bon oh there's bows and
arrows and equipment here for you ok
wait we're in the middle of almost where
you ran you you ported in and there were
like two inches from you and then you
ran the wrong way like like really
stupidly ok put on that armor we're
gonna duel we're gonna do all you you
come out of that house I'll come out of
this place and then turn around a
shootin don't get dysentery on the way
ok ready alright ready hey I'm hang on
hang on I'm ready
alright you take your time
give me like two seconds okay all right
all right no problem
ready no no no God what the hell takes
so long just just chill out I am
chilling oh that's the sound very chill
to me
I'm just imitating the villagers Oh love
you oh oh all right ready ready ooh wah
wah wah wait hand walk how do we walk we
shift yeah where my my ooh
okay now line up and then we're gonna
turn around take 10 faces and come out
of shooting you ready you ready okay
yeah around ten paces ah one one two
three three four five six seven eight
eight nine ten ten thousand ah oh wait
we don't dodge like ever ha ha ha really
oh I don't love your show I'm a terrible
shot apparently uh grinder I just no no
dude stop bouncing away I'm gonna go
away oh crap Edie we go oh come on come
on whoa aah aah stop moving stop alia
weirdo oh really
stop moving oh yeah long shot
whatever he's lucky he's lucky oh my god
from the sky yeah what the hell Wade
what whoa no way just died right in
front of me did he just get hung yeah he
did the magical sky demon hung Wade you
just got stabbed in the back Wow
why why why would you do this to me go
back yeah get over here
watchers want to do truth oh my god
another weight is getting hung oh my god
what's happening
I don't know but it is horrific that's
not good okay anyway so what should we
do now that we've done this probably
keep killing each other
no no oh man dysentery oh maybe it's
like on a random timer and we just
randomly get dysentery
ah don't kill me don't kill me I'm sick
zagging ah here little here I only have
one heart
oh those here don't kill me ah can't hit
me
AHA okay hit me alright idea okay me
haha I hate you yeah I know I know I
know you hit me okay alright okay so now
we're even totally even right no need to
kill each other ever again right right
oh oh
nozzle speed thick around like that okay
dance more dance yuck yuck yuck
hi maybe we should do something
productive here maybe maybe the end
lesson that we needed to get takeaway
from this is that Oregon is within
ourselves is that Oregon is horrible
hahaha yeah that's probably it Oregon
and whatever place we left from to get
to Oregon are both horrible
dibs what what whoa whoa whoa whoa what
the hi bye I want that what that oh no I
can't place blocks out there you go okay
the ball Oh me I dare you the moral of
the story is that Oregon is a pretty
shitty place and if you have lots and
lots and lots and lots of tea and tea
like we do you should probably blow it
up right right ah right correct probably
and I got okay I'll help out I'm gonna
place it inside the buildings we're
gonna detonate this sumbitch oh you
don't light it while I'm in there old
school don't light it while I'm in there
okay got this one no I'm not I'm not
the donkey I gotta do this you're not
the donkey what does that even mean
you're not you know whether you're not
wait is that what you're trying to say
is that is that what you were going for
oh I'm saying that I'm not a donkey I'm
a human and I understand what you want
me to do right now oh okay oh no oh no
okay it only got that side the rest of
the tnt is just fine so how did I
accidentally light it with another team
papa
yeah maybe some malevolent force just
decided to do something did you just
apologize to an NPC villager no ah
dysentery pipes are into my blocks hey
little friend a thumbs over here no way
yeah yeah no God that don't air
explosives go Oh doesn't Dario dysentery
they probably got blowed up you know cuz
you know how you blew up just happen
wait I see a magical beaming being in
the sky wait it just vanished
what the hell what the hell's going on
Bob this does are strange times don't
make no sense best you just kill
everybody best best thing to do it
alright are we ready to light this
sumbitch wait I got some more I'm all
out we need to got a little bit o a
little bit more if I could get myself
out of this hole I'm surprised those
zombies that are on fire are not
lighting the TNT ready ready no no no
real no no no no no okay all right then
oh oh no no aah
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha but in big the
creeper would get me for about there
well that happened Oh safe in my water
you were like in the movies you ducked
in the water cuz I would obvious that
would actually offer some protection ah
ha ha hey wait a minute there's things
underneath
the thing here what is all that it's
like lava little bits of lava they
disappeared okay anyway so we're done
here
the Oregon Trail mission failed from the
beginning because Oregon never existed
in the first place and then yeah so the
lesson that you should take from this is
blow things up with Tina oh yeah blow
things up with TNT Oregon horrible wade
makes a good donkey and that's it so
thank you all so much for watching
thanks Bob for being here
bye everybody bye Wade bye Bob thanks
Abby
Twitter subscribe blah blah blah thank
you all so much for watching
wait well y ou ha is coming back
wait wait I'll wire hey I'll blog about
can't get in now wait no I can't place
ha ha god wide why are there we go okay
oh oh all right well you're down there
forever now so thank you everybody so
much for watching click the annotations
more videos that we've done and as
always we'll see you in the next video